Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and this week
for Bonus Game of Thrones because Charles
Dance teased we hadn’t seen the last of
him, I wanted to talk about top 10 dead characters
we’d like to see come back.
George RR Martin has always been good about
teasing the potential to see old characters
again through flashbacks, resurrection and
reanimation.
And just a reminder to any new people, World
of Ice and Fire is out at the end of the month.
So when we get closer to that I’ll be randomly
giving away a couple of copies.
So be sure to subscribe so you don’t miss
any of that stuff!
Here’s my Top 10 I’d like to see back,
and I’ll explain how I’d like them to
come back.
Careful for spoilers through season 4 on the
show.
I’ll wait just a sec...okay, here we go.
Number 10 - The Giants Killed in the sacking
of Castle Black as Wights
I feel like we all want to see some zombie
giants.
The show didn’t make it very clear but the
giant that Grenn killed in the tunnel was
Mag the Mighty.
Giants don’t have kings, but Mag was something
of a leader for their tribe.
Mance Rayder says there’s only a couple
hundred of them left.
The only other one we know about that has
a name is Wun Wun, who’s even bigger than
Mag.
There’s a chance he could appear in Season
5 now that the wildling army has been subdued
by Stannis.
9 - Renly coming back in Visions to haunt
Loras
We haven’t seen a lot of ghosts in the series.
Visions are the next closest thing.
I just like the idea that Renly Haunts Loras.
The show is doing a little more with the character
than the books are.
Here’s a picture of Finn Jones on the set
of season 5.
They’ve been filming a lot of King’s Landing
scenes the past couple of weeks.
Vision Renly doesn’t have to be a bad thing.
Just like a dark passenger who visits Renly
in his dreams.
We didn’t see a ton of Renly thanks to Melisandre,
but Renly in the books was even more nuts
about pageantry.
So if he did haunt Loras’ dreams, it would
probably be with a never ending tourney.
The way I think about Renly in the books is
that he was a theater geek with crazy amounts
of money.
8 - Grenn the Giantslayer brought back as
a Wight
They burned all the bodies after the sack
of Castle Black.
So technically this is impossible.
But Grenn dying in the tunnel was one of the
changes the show made to the book story.
He started out as the asshole that was bullying
Samwell in season 1, one of the brothers that
Jon fought off.
By the wildling attack in season 4 though
he had matured a lot as a character and gladly
gave his life for the rest of the brotherhood.
Thus we remember him as Grenn the Giantslayer.
7 - Ygritte coming back to Jon Snow as a Vision
Her body was also burned, so the only way
she can come back is as a vision or a flashback.
But Jon just seems like the kind of character
who is constantly haunted by spirits.
Least of all his parents.
Both real and adoptive.
So far Ygritte is one of the few guides he’s
had.
I feel like he learned just as much with her
in his short time north of the wall as he
did in all 16 or 17 years growing up in Winterfell.
One of the reasons I encourage you all to
read the books is because you get to see inside
his head.
Particularly during Book 5.
I’d really like to see him conjure up Ygritte
as a way for his subconscious to manifest
itself and give him advice.
It would be like Jon telling himself he knows
nothing.
6 - Khal Drogo as a flashback
I just want Jason Momoa back on the show being
crazy.
He was burned too, so the only way he’s
coming back is in non-corporeal form.
Daenerys looks like she’s staying put in
Meereen for the time being, but at some point
she’s going to have to march an army somewhere.
I’d like to see her conjure up Khal Drogo
as a way to reassure herself during her conquest.
Khal Drogo as he was as a Warlord.
We really only saw him in and around his wedding
and short journey to the western coastline.
He became Khal because he was such a great
warlord.
So he’d probably have some pretty good advice
to give in battle.
5 - Catelyn Stark reanimated by the Red God
I feel like this is obligatory.
She’s not my favorite character I’d like
to see, but she still an important one in
the greater scheme of the books.
I’ll be interested to see how the show fills
that gap.
Like who will they give the big vengeance
arc to.
I do think they dropped the character, but
that doesn’t mean they dropped the role
she serves in the narrative.
4 - The Mountain reanimated as a Golem for
Clegane Bowl
It was implied that Qyburn was getting his
frankenstein on in the season 4 finale.
So I’d just like to see that taken to the
logical next step.
It seemed like the show wanted the Hound to
die too, but since we didn’t see it happen
on screen it’s possible they could bring
him back.
For those that haven’t seen the Clegane
Bowl forum threads, it’s just the idea that
circumstances could allow The Mountain and
The Hound to face off in a big epic battle.
Like their own version of Oberyn Martell vs
The Mountain.
Except they just hack each other to pieces.
There are all kinds of theories, so maybe
I’ll talk more about Clegane Bowl in a future
video.
3 - Tywin Lannister reanimated by the Red
God
Recently Charles Dance said that we had not
seen the last of Twyin.
I don’t think that means he’s coming back
to life on the show.
I just think we’ll see the funeral.
New seasons of the show always pick up in
the moments right after the previous season’s
finale.
So they’ll just address what happens with
the body of the most powerful man in Westeros.
I’d really love to see his character brought
back by the red god.
He only had a bunch of poison, rotting insides
and a few holes in his chest.
It’s not like half his face had fallen off.
It’s a lot of fun to see beloved characters
come back, but I think it’s just as awesome
to see crazy villains return.
2 - Oberyn Martell reanimated
I’d actually like to see Oberyn brought
back as a headless reanimated corpse.
Like the headless horseman from sleepy hollow.
Only he wields his spear.
and finally, the number character I want to
see again is Robert Baratheon as a Flashback.
Just so we can see what he learned at the
battle of the Trident when he killed Rhaegar
Targaryen.
He was supposedly the only person to hear
his dying words.
When Rhaegar died he supposedly whispered
someone’s name.
I think it was Lyanna Stark, but Martin hasn’t
given any explicit information about that.
He did say we would get more Robert’s Rebellion
flashbacks in the future books though.
So we will learn what actually happened.
Let me know though, which confirmed dead character
do you want to see again and how do you want
the show or the books to bring them back.
Remember, there’s a lot of literary devices
for bringing people back.
Just as a bonus, I would like to see Flashbacks
for The Mad King and Rhaegar Targaryen, but
I think sometimes it’s better that they
don’t do those things just so my imagination
can fill in the gaps.
That’s why reading the books can be more
fun at times, you just get the chance to imagine
something so much crazier than what they’re
capable of doing on the show.
Speaking of which, congratulations to this
week’s giveaway winner i love popcorn.
I’ll reach out to you on your channel for
details.
A lot of people die each year but I’ve already
done a video about one potential ending for
the series.
You can click here to learn more about that
and click here for more of my season 5 predictions.
A lot of stuff changing from the books.
Thanks for watching, everybody high five and
I’ll see you tonight for Gotham!